TREATY BY FIVE YEARS.
IN AMERICA'S ELECTION
HEADQUARTERS TONIGHT, WE TOLD
YOU A MOMENT AGO THAT EARLY
VOTING BEGAN HERE IN FLORIDA
TODAY.
IT STARTED SATURDAY IN NEVADA.
A SHORT TIME AGO,
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA HELD A
RALLY IN LAS VEGAS TO DRUM UP
ENTHUSIASM FOR DEMOCRATS RUNNING
A CLOSE RACE IS FOR THE SENATE,
HOUSE AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
PETER DOOCY IS IN LAS VEGAS
TONIGHT.
>> HELLO NEVADA.
>> BARACK OBAMA WON NEVADA TWICE
BUT SENATOR OF DEAN HELLER
TRYING TO WIN AGAINST JACKIE
ROSEN THINKS THAT'S PLENTY.
>> THE BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HER AND I, SHE TAKES US BACK TO
THE OBAMA ERA.
>> UNLIKE SOME, I TRY TO
ACTUALLY STATE FACTS, I BELIEVE
IN FACTS.
>> THE FORMER DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT IS CURRENTLY THE
PARTY'S TOP SURROGATE AND HE
RALLIED FOR ROSEN ON THE CAMPUS
OF UNLV.
>> IF REPUBLICANS KEEP CONGRESS
THIS FALL, YOU BETTER BELIEVE
THEY ARE COMING AFTER
HEALTH CARE AGAIN.
AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHO COUNT ON THIS
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE IT.
EVEN REPUBLICANS, THEY JUST
DON'T KNOW IT.
>> SENATOR HELLER THINGS ROSEN
SPECIAL GUESTS WILL MISS THE
MARK.
>> NEVADA WAS WIPED OUT DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
60% OF OUR HOMES WERE UNDERWATER
HERE IN THE STATE.
>> WITH A 20 TO TEN ELECTION
DEMOCRATS LOST THE HOUSE.
TWO YEARS INTO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FIRST TERM OF THE 2018 ELECTIONS
APPROACHING, AND HIS APPROVAL
RATING IS TWO POINTS HIGHER,
47%, AND HE'S TRYING TO USE IT
TO HELP HELLER.
>> President Trump: I HAVE TO
THANK DEAN HELLER FOR HELPING US
WITH JUSTICE GORSUCH AND JUSTICE
CAVANAUGH.
>> HE HAS A RUBBER ONE OF
TRUMP'S NOMINATION WITHOUT EVEN
GIVING IT A SECOND THOUGHT.
NEVADA WANTS AN INDEPENDENT
VOICE.
>> IN THE FIRST TWO DAYS OF
EARLY VOTING, DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
CAST 45% OF THE VALID AND
REPUBLICANS CAST 36%.
BUT SENATOR HELLER LIKES HIS
CHANCES BECAUSE HE THINKS THE
CAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION CHAOS
KEPT THE G.O.P. EXCITED JUST
LONG ENOUGH.
>> LET ME TELL YOU MY CONCERN ON
ALL OF THIS.
KAVANAUGH HAPPENED TOO QUICK.
I WANTED THAT MOMENTUM TO
CONTINUE TO EARLY VOTING, AND IT
HAS OCCURRED.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA'S PITCH HERE
ON BEHALF OF DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES WAS LESS ABOUT THEIR
RECORDS AND MORE ABOUT HIS OWN
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
BUT THE CROWD ATE IT UP, ROUGHLY
2,000 PEOPLE CAME TO HEAR HIM
SPEAK AND THAT IS LESS THAN HALF